egyptian cookies are basically these
soft milky cookies stuffed with
pistachio and honey i honestly just care
about the powdered sugar on top
hi i'm amrohalmi and today i'm going to
show you how to make the egyptian cake
cookies in order to make the perfect
cake you have to have yeast flour and
cinnamon it doesn't involve a lot of
sugar in it so i think cinnamon is the
secret flavor that makes it special we
make cookies only once a year right
after ramadan we have feasts and
basically this is the most magical time
of the year and we just eat milky
cookies stuffed with pistachio and
covered with sugar this cat cook is not
just cookies they're home their mom
their dad their friends their family
their everything they're a very special
moment in life how can you say no to
this while the dough rests let's move on
to the pistachio and honey we want to be
able to get the ghee and the flour to a
brown goldish color it should smell
really nutty then we add the sesame and
the honey and we just want to keep
stirring it until it's thick these
cookies are very important to me because
my mom lives in cairo right now i
haven't seen her in six years they
remind me of a lot of things that i
haven't experienced in a while i haven't
experienced home i haven't seen my mom i
haven't hugged my mom in a while so i
feel like this means a lot i feel like
these cookies going to send me back home
i remember my mom used to not let me and
my twin sister help her make cookies
because they used to always be at really
wrong shape and she always hated the
fact that it would grow in the design so
i remember she eventually let us make
them and she would make two different
plates one her designs and one my and my
sister's designs at restaurants and
shops you can find these cat cookies
designed really cute and super fancy but
at home we just keep it simple there's
this specific tool that they use to
design but if you don't have it you can
always use a fork and just keep it
simple and my favorite part ever is the
powdered sugar the cinnamon and the
powdered sugar they make perfect
combination my favorite way of eating
cookie is with tea english breakfast tea
works green tea works coffee works but
for me it's tea you take a bite you take
a sip
this is exactly how my mom does it
oh yes
you